The vertex shader performs the transform of the vertex position to the screen.
Its inputs are the vertex from the triangle along with whatever data the
programmer wants to provide. For example, matrices and the colorful material
could be passed in. The output of the vertex shader is a vertex with a
transformed position. And possibly other information, such as the normal. The
transform triangle is then rasterized. Triangle set up sends the data at each
pixel inside a triangle to another programmable unit, the fragment shader. If
you use Microsoft's DirectX API, this is called the pixel shader. Here's the
layout for the fragment shader. This shader is handed various information from
the triangle being processed. Somewhere to the vertex shader, the programmer
can feed in any other data needed to process the triangles data at each pixel.
The fragment shader's program is run, and the output not surprisingly, called a
fragment Is typically a color and a z-depth, and possibly an alpha if you're
using transparency. By the way, the reason we call it a fragment is that it
represents the piece of the triangle covered by the pixel. At this point, this
fragment color plus z-depth, is compared to the stored depth in the z-buffer.
If the fragment is closer than the z-depth previously stored. The triangle is
visible at this pixel and its color values are saved. The z-buffer test is
again a fixed function bit of hardware. Notice how the fragment shader is
pretty similar to the vertex shader in the way it functions. In fact, modern
GPUs use what is called a unified shader in the hardware itself. These shader
processors are assigned on the fly by the GPU, to execute vertex shader or
fragment shader programs, depending on where the bottleneck is found.